we turn now to a new challenge to the
Muller investigation Andrew Miller an
associate of Trump campaigned advisor
Roger stone was held in contempt after
intentionally that is strategically
refusing to testify before Washington
grand jury on Friday
Miller's attorney is questioning the
constitutionality of the whole
investigation it has been a week of
major political developments in
Washington for a closer look we turn to
Shelby Holliday a reporter for The Wall
Street Journal Shelby good morning good
morning let's start right there Andrew
Miller held in contempt you wrote on
Friday about Roger stone becoming more
scrutinized in the investigation what
can you tell us yes this was just one
piece of news Andrew Miller is
intentionally defying his subpoena as
you said it seems to be a strategy so
that he can challenge this the contempt
order
he had already challenged the special
counsels authority a judge struck that
down but now he plans to challenge again
so we'll see where that goes we also saw
a close associate of Roger stones Randy
credit go get a subpoena yesterday
Randy credit go is who Roger stone says
was his back channel to WikiLeaks during
the 2016 election now Roger stone is
under scrutiny because he communicated
with WikiLeaks and a persona goose' 42.0
that the special counsels office said
was a front for Russian intelligence
Russian intelligence that hacked emails
and later distributed them on WikiLeaks
so Roger stones communications with
these two groups are raising a lot of
questions and Randy critical may be able
to shed some light on that we also saw
testimony yesterday before the grand
jury of another stone associate Kristin
Davis unclear though what she would know
about his his contacts with Julian
Assange were or anyone in Russia still
up in the air as this potential sit-down
with the president what do you know
about this how did this impact anyone
reporting on this will say will believe
it when we see it despite the special
counsels office and Trump's lawyers have
been going back and forth since January
about the scope of a possible interview
there have been some counter offers and
most of what we're learning are it's
coming from the president's team so we
don't exactly have the special counsel
side of this story but the president's
team wants to limit the scope they don't
want the president to be asked about
obstruction of justice they've
previously said they don't want him
talking about his business dealings and
they also suggested that he write
answers to the special counsels
questions and
prosecutor you talk to you says that's
highly unlikely molar we'll go for that
so at this point again we'll see it when
we believe it when we see it yeah yeah
they talk about a potential perjury trap
for the president kind of a dubious
concept there if you tell the truth I
don't know how it can be a trap
right a trial that is going on right now
the Paul Manafort trial that's a tax
fraud case but it could be tied into
another case on collusion down the line
walk us through how that mana Ford case
could potentially connect to the larger
Russia investigation right so this is
one of two trials there will be another
Paul Manafort trial in September this
case is you know it started off with the
ostrich vest and the Python jacket and
some of the flashy things mana for it
was buying but very quickly the
prosecution got into his financial
troubles and how much debt he was in in
2016 if you're looking at some of the
exhibits uploaded by the special counsel
two things are very clear there's a
paper trail that shows Paul Manafort was
masterminding some of these alleged
schemes to what the prosecutors say
launder money get fraudulent loans he
was lying to banks now Manafort will
present his defense of this but another
thing that really sticks out is there is
a lot of back-and-forth between Paul
Manafort and a man named Constantine
Coulomb neck the special counsels office
has said Constantine clinic had ties to
Russian intelligence in 2016 and it if
you look at the evidence he was
facilitating payments to mana for it
from some pro-russian Ukrainians and he
came to the u.s. to meet with manna for
it in 2016 during the campaign Wow manna
fort was the campaign manager so these
are some of the tea leaves we're looking
at that could lead to any sort of
possible charges telling the devil is in
the details LV Holliday thanks so much
for joining us thanks for having me